Beetlejuice Beetlejuice beetlejuice with
three words Tim Burton summoned one of
the most iconic horror comedies to ever
hit the Silver Screen this is what the
original cast looks like now
there are lots of big names in the cast
of Beetlejuice but the movie was never
going to work if the actor playing the
Title Character didn't commit 100
luckily Michael Keaton is at the top of
his game channeling every bit of Sly
humor cocky attitude and simmering
Menace he's got to create one of his
most memorable roles ever the character
became a massive force in pop culture on
the strength of Keaton's spectacular
performance it's showtime the actor has
had a bit of a Renaissance in recent
years it isn't like he ever truly
disappeared but his old puts in the
2000s was dramatically reduced from his
star power in the late 1980s and early
1990s his career Resurgence really began
in 2014 when he was nominated for an
Oscar for his work in Birdman or the
unexpected virtue of ignorance Keaton's
recent roles have acknowledged his own
superhero passed as a star of Batman and
Batman Returns he played Adrian tombs
aka the vulture in Spider-Man homecoming
and in a post-credits scene for morbius
and to reprise the Caped Crusader in the
flash but Keaton's latest scream roles
haven't been all capable in comics he
earned an Emmy and Golden Globe was both
actor and co-producer of the
hard-hitting 2021 miniseries dope SEC as
well as netting Screen Actors Guild and
independent Spirit awards for the 2015
drama Spotlight that same year he was
also made an officer of the order of
arts and letters by the French Ministry
of culture
Barb honey
we're dead
I don't think we have very much to worry
about anymore it's understandable if he
didn't initially recognize Alec Baldwin
and Beetlejuice if you only know the
actor from his more written roles it
could be tough to tell it up for Adam
one half of the couple that's killed
early in the film and has to learn to
cope with haunting their old home is
played by the most well-known member of
the Baldwin acting Clan Baldwin has an
impressive career with a huge variety of
roles as his booming voice Charisma and
Rise sense of humor allow him to play
comedy and drama equally well some of
his biggest mainstream successes have
come on television he starred on a
series 30 Rock You may have recognized
his voice as a narrator on Thomas and
Friends when he got seriously under the
skin of Donald Trump by playing him as
an obnoxious buffoon on Saturday Night
Live Baldwin's movie career has evolved
from leading man roles in The Hunt for
Red October to richer character turns
and the cooler which earns him an Oscar
nomination in 2003. as well as Martin's
corsets The Aviator and The Departed and
two entries in a mission impossible
franchise he also lents his voice to
animated feature boss baby and proved
capable of equip as the host of a match
game Revival unfortunately Baldwin
netted more headlines in recent years
for a 2021 incident on the set of the
Indie Western rust where his prop gun
discharged and killed cinematographer
Helena Hutchins charges of involuntary
manslaughter brought against Baldwin by
the Santa Fe County New Mexico District
Attorney's Office were dropped in 2023.
the Maitland's terrible tragedy kicks
off the story in Beetlejuice and we
don't get a ton of time to really get to
know them before we're thrown into their
crazy afterlife experience luckily Gina
Davis is there to keep us grounded the
active players have recently deceased
Barbara Maitland and she's got both the
emotional and comedic chops to make her
character one of the film's most
memorable Gina Davis was one of the
biggest stars of the 80s and 90s she was
part of iconic films like Thelma and
Louise and the League of Their Own and
earned an Academy Award for best
supporting actress for her turn in
1988's The Accidental Taurus Davis also
appeared in noteworthy genre films as
well including David cronenberg's
reimagining of the fly and Stuart Little
in recent years Davis has done some of
her best work on television winning a
Golden Globe and Emmy nomination for a
short-lived drama commander-in-chief and
appearing a notable recurring roles on
shows like Gray's Anatomy glow and Shira
and the princesses of power she also
started the Gina Davis Institute on
gender in media which strives for change
in the hiring practices of Phil Roman
Television Studios
I myself am strange and unusual
so says Lydia Deeds The Eccentric
teenager who befriends and go see
maitlands after her family moves into
their former home Lydia was a perfect
role in which the cast would own a
writer who had made quite the name for
herself playing Dark Oddball characters
in the Heyday of her career like many of
her castmates in Beetlejuice Winona
Ryder was a huge deal in the 80s and 90s
she embodied edgy teens and
20-somethings and several decade
defining films during that time frame
including Heather's Bram Stoker's
Dracula Reality Bites and Girl
Interrupted as well as another beloved
Tim Burton film and with Scissorhands
she also proved equally skilled at drama
earning Oscar nods for both Little Women
and Martin scorsese's the Age of
Innocence her career slowed down
significantly after her 2001 arrest for
shoplifting but Ryder has regained
plenty of fans who have more recent
roles some of her best work has been
featured on television including a
Golden Globe nominated Turner's
protective mum Joyce buyers on stranger
things and her starring role in the plot
against America Birches also maintained
her film career through he features like
gone in the night and Studio Projects
such as Black Swan and the upcoming
Haunted Mansion she will play an adult
Lydia dates in Beetlejuice too
but I must express myself
if you don't let me cut out this house
and make it my own I will go and stay
and I will take you with me since first
gaining Fame as an emmy-winning writer
and cast member of the groundbreaking
SCTV sketch comedy series Catherine
O'Hara has remained one of the best
comedic actresses of the past four
decades her taken a self-absorbed artist
Delia deeds and Beetlejuice as a
testimony to her talent and even a bit
of a precursor to one of her most
notable roles Moira rose on shit's creek
which earned her Emmy Golden Globe and
Screen Actors Guild Awards you might
know her as he exasperated but caring
mother Kate in home alone and Home Alone
2 lost in New York Bert O'Hara has a
long history of playing eccentric
characters and features most notably in
several of Christopher gas absurdist
mockumentaries including waiting for
government and A Mighty Wind she's
enjoyed character roles in Martin's
scorsese's after hours as well as the
paper and lent her distinct voice to
dozens of animated features including
Burtons that Nightmare Before Christmas
and Frankenweenie as well as a 2019
Adams Family
television is where the actress has made
her biggest Mark in recent years and
she's moved between both live action and
Voice work with ease her on-screen guest
roles include the optometrist Dr Orwell
On A Series of Unfortunate Events as
well as appearances on 30 Rock Modern
Family and the kids and the whole
Revival her animated TV work included
Skylanders Academy and the last kids on
Earth she'll next lend her voice to the
Walt Disney Pictures slash Pixar feature
Elemental and will appear in Matthew
Vaughn's Argyle
Jeffrey Jones is one of those actors who
was in a turn of 80s comedies that was
always better known by his character's
names and his own in Beetlejuice he
plays Charles Dietz a stereotypical
dorky at stud who just wants some peace
and choir Jones's career moved through
both comedies and drama and he was known
for several huge films throughout the
1980s and 90s he played the emperor in
Amadeus and also appeared in films like
The Hunt for Red October and the devil's
AdvoCare on the comedy front Jones is
probably best known for playing Dean Ed
Rooney in Ferris Bueller's Day Off anti
reunited with Tim Burton to appear in
Edward in 1994. however Jones's acting
career was derailed by some serious
criminal charges in 2002 he was arrested
for possession of child pornography and
several related allegations Jones has
also gotten in trouble with the law over
the years for not updating his offender
status and the federal database he still
acts on occasion such as portraying aw
American HBO series Deadwood and the
2019 film but it's rarely in anything
too notable and understandably so
among the guests at the dinner party and
one of the horror comedy's most
memorable scenes is a man named Bernard
he's a short amount in the suits with a
white shirt and red tie Bernard is
played by Dick Cavett it would have been
instantly recognizable to most audiences
as an acclaims talk show host author and
raconteur Calvert is best known for
being a comedian and talk show host he
got to start writing and scouting for
new Talent under tonight's show for host
jackpar and Johnny Carson he eventually
branched out to start his own talk show
the dick covet show which aired in a
variety of channels from 1968 to 1996
though it never quite achieved the
mainstream success of similar programs
the series won two Emmys because of his
Fame as a media personality covert
frequently played himself in films like
Annie Hall Forrest Gump and A Nightmare
on Elm Street 3 The Dream Warriors he
also was and remains an in-demand
subject and interview for countless
documentaries the most recent of these
was HBO's Ali and Cavett the tale of the
tapes which featured his interviews with
the boxing great and the 2022 episode of
American Justice called Groucho and
Cavett which detailed his long
friendship with the comedy Legend
we're very unhappy what did you expect
you're dead it's hard to think of
Beetlejuice and not remember Tim
Burton's Classic design of the afterlife
a massive bureaucratic infrastructure
for the receptionists and caseworkers
the afterlife is forever so it makes
sense you'd have to wait the Maitland's
caseworker is a woman named Juno who
greets them with a smoker's rasp to lay
out the rules now that they're dead Juno
is played by classic film actor Sylvia
Sydney Sydney's first credited role came
all the way back in 1926 as an extra in
DW Griffith's silent film The Sorrows of
Satan so she'd already been in the game
for a number of years when Tim Burton
Came Calling she Rose to fame during the
1930s under renowned directors appearing
in films like Sabotage by Alfred
Hitchcock and fury by Fritz Lang in the
1950s she played fontine in a film
version of Les Miserables and she was
nominated for an Oscar for a role in
summer wishes Winter Dreams in 1973.
Sydney continued to work in the years
after Beetlejuice and reunited with Tim
Burton to play Grandma Norris whose
affection for singer slim Whitman's
yodel save the world Mars Attacks Sydney
died of cancer at the age of 88 on July
1 1999.
then the crew of lovable weirdos who
populates him Burton's Beetlejuice few
stand taller than otho Delia's interior
designer is full of smug 80s confidence
and he's played by well-loved character
actor Glenn shadix Burton loves to find
actors who fit his style and casts them
again and again and shadix is a great
example besides playing gotho shadix has
also appeared in Burton's Planet of the
Apes as Senator Nado and he graced many
of our childhoods by voicing the mayor
of Halloweentown in The Nightmare Before
Christmas which Burton helped create he
also had memorable bit Parts in films
like Heathers and Demolition Man among
others shardix was also known for voice
acting and he put together an impressive
resume of work in that regard in
addition to nightmare shattuck's voice
characters in Teen Titans the Fantastic
Voyages of Sinbad the Sailor and Jackie
Chan Adventures The Voice work was
essential at shattuck's physical health
rapidly declined later in his career and
he used a wheelchair for Mobility sadly
the actor died in 2010 only 58 years old
after falling in his home
when nadid's family realizes that the
house is haunted they decide to turn it
into a tourist destination rather than
fleeing in Terror Charles big plan
involves inviting his old boss to the
house as a potential investor that boss
Maxi Dean is played by none other than
Robert Goulet Goulet got his start and
made his living for most of his life as
a singer his acting career actually
kicked off because of his Broadway
notoriety as Goulet when both Tony and
Grammy Awards during his impressive
career he was known for a deep velvety
voice and had a number of stage
standards and Lounge hits as a singer
due to his celebrity Goulet regularly
played himself in film and on television
he appeared multiple times on Mr
Belvedere and you can also catch him in
Scrooged and other titles in roles other
than Robert Goulet is most notable
probably came from the Naked Gun two and
a half the smell of fear isn't that
right Mr Poopy Pants that does it with a
voice like his it's no surprise that
goulet's work can be heard in animated
projects too he played Mikey on the
series recess and also voiced Wheezy the
penguin in Toy Story 2. Goulet died in
2007 at the age of 73.
another of the party guests in the
deet's household when Beetlejuice
finally starts wreaking havoc Grace is a
woman wearing the shiny gold dress she
is played by Susan Kellerman who made
appearances in a number of 80s and 90s
comedies though rarely as a featured
actor Kellerman got started in comedy by
playing small television roles on shows
like Laverne and Shirley and Starsky and
Hutch she also had a recurring role on
Taxi as a mother to Andy Kaufman's
character as Kellerman's career
continued she seemed to pick up roles in
comedy films in the same dark and quirky
vein as Beetlejuice she shows up as
party in Elvira Mistress of the dark and
as a doctor in Death Becomes Her she
also voiced a variety of characters
across several episodes of the Animated
Series Croatia Cowardly Dog Kellerman
never quite became a famous name like
many other actors in Beetlejuice but she
clearly found plenty of success over the
years her work has slowed down recently
and her last credited role came in 2016.
it might be safe to say she's retired
yet anotherly unfortunate guess of the
Beetlejuice in a party gone wrong is
Barrel she is a woman wearing the green
dress and the bow on top of her head
very well is played by artist Adele Lutz
who may have actually been an
inspiration for some of Delia's more
esoteric pieces let's appeared in a
handful of films in a short acting
career and actually put together an
impressive resume even though her
primary career is as an artist in the
80s she appeared in films like Wall
Street and something wild and she played
a TV anchor in 1991's the Silence of the
Lambs her last role came in 1995 in John
borman's film Beyond Rangoon as an
artist lets us known to combine elements
of fashion and sculpture to create her
work she has contributed designs to
works by theater director Robert Wilson
and musicians ranging from Michael Stipe
and Bono to her former husband David
Byrne of Talking Heads her work has
appeared in numerous magazines and
promotional campaigns over several
decades and has been featured in museums
around the world including the
Metropolitan Museum of Art and the
Fashion Institute of Technology